in his new podcast and upcoming book Moe
bitchu Aires CBS Sunday morning
correspondent Mo Rocca looks at
extraordinary people like meter whose
names you may not know raka gives them
his own version of an obituary or as he
calls it a mobit his book is published
by Simon & Schuster a division of CBS he
also looks at celebrities like Audrey
Hepburn and how her death was
overshadowed in 1993 she died on the
same day as President Clinton's
inauguration Wow good morning pushed her
right off the front page yeah my
goodness why have you decided on obits
have you always been interested I've
always loved to owe bets and you know
there are people I've long been
fascinated by and I thought they didn't
get the send-off they deserved or they
didn't get any send-off at all so you
know we're doing episodes on Audrey
Hepburn and on neanderthals it was never
an obituary for Neanderthals when they
died out 40,000 years ago so it's a
whole range of some oh they've been
around recently but it's really about
your life and not really a death and
you're taking a look at that absolutely
I'd never thought of it that way
actually until yeah exactly I think a
good obituaries about the life of a
person right rather than their death and
and you know and these are people also
that I feel sort of a personal
connection to I aren't yet brain you're
right good night in 1992 I was working
at Macy's behind the fragrance counter I
was and and Audrey Hepburn walked right
by my counter and I'm telling you the
floor just the main floor there it just
fell silent I mean even if there had
been cellphones back there you never
would have shoved your hand in front of
her face for a selfie so what's
something in the Moe bitchu area that we
might not know about Audrey Hepburn so I
wanted to answer the question why 26
years after her death does she still
trend on Twitter why are we still so
attached to her her career was only
about 14 years long there were stars
that were bigger than she was but
there's something there's she has a hold
on us so we go into her personal history
for war years and we hypothesize that
what you see on camera is really rooted
in kind of her
childhood and and what she went through
and that's there's something part of
punching through is the history of the
person of course but then the times in
which they live which is rich as well
yeah exactly like with Sammy Davis jr.
who you know it's it's it's axiomatic
that he could do it all and he really
could do it all just a brilliant
entertainer but that whole era is gone
to where the marketplace appreciated
somebody who could do it all is it were
variety shows I like sitcom deaths and
disappearances that I never even thought
about this number when you say that you
loved TV since you were a little boy at
nine you memorized a TV Guide that's
about you the neighbor didn't even know
that you existed here in TV all the time
but you talk about Chuck Cunningham from
Happy Days he just went upstairs and
never came down the little girl on
Family Matters Judy Winslow also walked
down the aisle in a wedding and just
sort of disappeared and no one ever
explained vaporize these people yeah
well so on hour-long dramas you know
people get killed off all the time I was
on Law & Order criminal intent and I
blew up in a car and on game fedora hat
- yes exactly and Game of Thrones 70% of
the characters get killed off that's an
actual statistic but in the sitcom
universe people don't die generally and
talk to Henry Winkler about what
happened to Ritchie Cunningham's older
brother Chuck Cunningham who was in the
first two seasons of happy days you
would bounce in a bow basket he would
usually be you know dribbling a
basketball or eating a sandwich and Gary
Marshall was so good at what he did the
creator of happy days that he decided
you know the Fonz was becoming so
popular Richie Cunningham would go to
the Fonz for advice on dating so the
bonds became the older brother and
rather than making Chuck Cunningham's
and disappearance a plot point he knew
that the audience would suspend
disbelief enough to just haven't be okay
with him just just just disappear so he
just went upstairs to his room yeah he
never came down right he's the relative
no one talked about it he was memorizing
the TV Guide apparently you want me over
by talking about Aunt Viv the to aunt
Viv's I'm there so thank you for that I
was a fan of the original just saying
right and if anyone remembers the vexing
problem of the two Darrin's gonna be wet
that's a different kind of disappearance
when actor disappears and the gallery
show
the lead character just sort of
disappeared well they did actually kill
her off Valerie Harper she was in a car
accident exactly they killed her off and
and replaced her character was seeing
Duncan and the mo [ __ ] where's podcast
the launches tomorrow in his book will
come out this fall oh and on today's see
business we're not gonna say no hurry up
ya have to subscribe superstar producer
Kate who's in her 20s says tell
everybody to subscribe rate and review I
don't know what she's talking about but
just do it oh I didn't know you're gonna
say that okay go ahead Nora